from the Philadelphia Eagles he's
Malcolm Jenkins here on the show how are
you Malcolm I'm doing what are you doing
I am doing just fine talking to you
let's start with the non football stuff
first if you wouldn't mind or the real
life stuff the real-world stuff what was
the reaction in the community in
Philadelphia to you raising your fists
during the national anthem as you have
been yeah I think you know starting you
have to go all the way back to you know
last August really last July I've always
been really active in the Philadelphia
community and I think people in the city
recognized you know those efforts so
when the season rolled around and
obviously all of those protests being
started you know I know
my reputation kind of goes before me
tomorrow my response here has been
mainly positive especially when people
track the work that I've done you know
since the beginning of last season on
issues of social justice and criminal
justice reform being able to work hand
in hand with the local police
departments with local grassroots
organizations so I think you know once
that that those efforts have been
documented in in showcase my experience
here especially in the Senate in
Philadelphia has been pretty public okay
and what did it mean for you to have
Chris Long put his arm on you a couple
weeks ago during the national anthem I
think I think it meant a lot I think it
was one of those things that just
continues the conversation in light of
what happened in Charlottesville and all
of the political division that that's
happened since last year's election I
think that was just that symbol of you
know although Chris might not
necessarily feel the same things that
we're fighting for it might not even
understand it or experience them but he
can still you know empathize and stand
in support and I think that's a message
that you know America needs right now
what
the team owner Jeffrey Lurie as he
reached out to you about this and if so
what of your what is your conversation
with him been about yeah well we've
talked he pulled me aside a couple of
times throughout even the offseason and
just you know let me know that he
supports me and he's proud of me for
being able to use this platform to speak
you know on all these issues and and and
that somebody you know needs to do it
and so I think you know I felt they're
very comfortable was doing not only the
the protest but also they work off the
field in these particular areas whether
it's going to DC talking on legislators
or and needing permission to go you know
during the week I've been allowed to do
that being active here in the local
community is setting up meetings with
the police they've been very very
helpful with that well in terms of that
Malcolm Jenkins the Eagles joining me
here on the show and qualm Bolden has
been with you and vice versa going to
Capitol Hill on these subjects and he
flat-out retired from the league saying
that he wants to do that and focus on
that without football in his life what
did you think of his retirement with
that statement Malcolm you know I I was
you know surprised that he retired but I
wasn't surprised at how passionate he
was about these issues
you know he's somebody I've been you
know hit him with this whole offseason
and all of the work when it comes you
know social justice and he's had
recently had you know a family member
killed you know by an officer who was
unarmed and and so a lot of these issues
that play you know across our TV screens
doesn't hit close to home it's in his
home and so I know how passionate he is
about using this platform to make change
so I wasn't really surprised is that
something you'd be thinking about doing
someday what Anquan just did it
retired or presenting you know during
this full time I think you know I'm
obviously football is my number one
thing right now and you know I love the
game and still have a lot of good years
to play but but I do think when
whenever that time is done and I'm done
with the game I think I will you know
obviously continue to use my platform
whether it's to my foundation or is
through activism to make sure that you
know I can I can make the world the
place that I wanted to be for my kids
now what are you what do you think of
Jim Browns comments recently that he
supports Colin Kaepernick but not the
way he's been going about it
disrespecting the national anthem in the
flag what do you think about that
Malcolm Jenkins I mean you know
obviously Jim Brown is somebody who's
got a long legacy of activism and it's
obviously a different way of approaching
it
you know his opinions on what's the
right way to demonstrate what's the
wrong way is you know his opinion I
think the biggest thing is guys starting
to use those platforms to not
necessarily draw attention to the
protest in itself we're starting to
really gear towards solutions geared
toward work and obviously Jim Brown was
one of those people who was very very
solution-based very in the community in
the prisons and I think it's time now to
start to move that conversation to the
work that that is actually being done
there are players that are doing a lot
of different things outside of the
protest that I think can benefit
communities in this country well that's
one of the comments from obviously a
goat in the Pro Football Hall of Fame
and then there's LeSean McCoy from the
current ranks of the National Football
League
saying that Kaepernick is not even that
good enough of a player to bring on a
team to invite whatever distraction or
chaos that might come from his
acquisition and I'm wondering is you as
a defender somebody who plays on the
other side of the ball would you agree
with that assessment of Colin Kaepernick
no I wouldn't just because I don't
consider what he's doing or what he did
last year a distraction um you know a
player who raised in my face every week
you know there's other players around
the league that taken the erasers
you know I don't think anybody feels
that they're irreplaceable or that you
know because they are this great of a
player that you know they're immune to
criticism or whatever I think that's a
ludicrous statement and like I said we
were talking about Colin Kaepernick
we're not talking about him being in
trouble or getting arrested we're
talking about him really standing up for
in justices and I think that context
needs to always be attached to it so I
you know those I think those comments
are unfortunate because you start to see
you know other athletes who don't
realize the platforms that they're
sitting on and then begin to criticize
other players who are using theirs well
I guess in a way he was saying that he's
just not even that good enough of a
player and he's an offensive player so I
guess he would know from the X's and O's
there but you your guy would have to
defend him and if you're actually if
Colin Kaepernick is good enough to play
in the NFL
I think he's proved that already and I
mean there's there's plenty of other
quarterbacks that would prove that he
belongs in the league Malcolm Jenkins
joining me here from the Philadelphia
Eagles couple more minutes and in terms
of football help me out with what the
Eagles are gonna look like this year I
mean you got a second-year quarterback
who who performed extremely well last
year you've got a second-year head coach
with now a full season under his under
his resume well what are the
Philadelphia Eagles gonna look like this
year in terms of goals oriented and then
wins losses Malcolm but you know I think
our goals are to win the division and we
feel like we're way more than capable of
doing that obviously we feel really good
about Carson in the second year and a
lot of new pieces without Sean Jeffery
Torrey Smith LeGarrette Blount Nelson
Aguilar is playing really well for us
that opens up you know more space for
exact errs and so I think our office you
know we feel really good about their
development and how they're gelling our
defense is in its second year we started
really really strong last year we want
to continue to build off of that
I think Tim Jernigan up front
system via beast force we got a Ronald
aubriana outside we got through a trade
that I think's solidifying some
questions we had that corner and another
night you know everybody else's their
second year and we feel real good about
it so I think you know the team is still
you know this last week of of kind of
evaluating whose will make the 53 but
you know we're in a division week one
and you know we're gonna come on swing
it alright and on a scale of one to ten
of one being we got this in ten is
absolutely beyond concerned what is your
concern level for Saturday November 25th
2013 Malcolm Jenkins 2017 pardon me
what's your concern level no 2017 what
do you what what what do you mean this
what do you what do you what do you mean
by we got this seriously we you there's
not even not even a serious concern
about going into the big house 2017 come
on I know you got bravado I know it's
it's the Ohio State and all that stuff
made it close in like 10 years
[Laughter]
I'm glad I'm glad the game is actually
watchable now oh come on now Malcolm you
know before you stepped on the campus in
Columbus Ohio these things are cyclical
you do realize that right that John you
know with you living and breathing on
the planet it has happened I mean you
just you you you just hadn't played
college football you okay is it possible
that you and I can revisit this issue
later on this fall yeah if you promise
to after you guys lose again if you
don't go into hiding we can definitely
talk about I will never go into hiding
you know where you can find me that's
number one okay that's number one number
two is how deep in in the referee's
pockets will will Ohio State be for that
one
[Music]
that's what I was looking for fantastic
man
Hey look I really love what you're doing
Malcolm I really enjoy watching you play
football and then and then realizing
that there's a greater aspect of life
and you know and I've really liked how
you're going about your business quite
frankly I appreciate that you got it and
you know I asked this of Chris long this
will be the last question for you
what do you say to the stick to sports
crowd Malcolm those who tune into the
National Football League to be
entertained not to have this
conversation placed next to their
escapism what do you say to that well
the biggest thing is I try to get people
to empathize with me I don't like
preaching to people but the NFL is made
up of 70% black athletes each of these
teams have stadiums or playing cities
that are in urban communities and so to
ignore some of the problems in those
communities I think would be wrong and
so even you know here in Philadelphia
you know as we look at we're approaching
Labor Day and we celebrate you know
people's rights to get jobs and provide
and then you can look into some
african-american communities communities
that are represent communities that I've
come from and I've seen how you know
people who made mistakes over the years
or our criminal justice system and stop
people from getting jobs and so there's
opportunities for us to highlight ways
to change that and we have that platform
we have that ability and so for me to
get on this stage and stay silent I
think would be just as wrong as somebody
who you know was trying to stop that
changes altogether okay well good luck
against Washington in Week one Malcolm
good luck against Indiana on Thursday
night for your team and like I told you
moments ago I really like what you're
doing and like Ohio State last November
I'm there for you the whole nine yards
okay take care that's uh Malcolm Jenkins
Malcolm Jenkins on Twitter the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy